sup Internet here we are with the tripod
oh my god on our job somewhere else it's
okay
throughout the woods with our friends
Coty Tanner Michael Sam Nico
John and Jake and David David are out in
Big Bear filming a sweet video a little
bit darker a little more narrative than
a narrative base in our other videos
that's about a poacher there in
Yellowstone Park when it's closed you
guys might remember Tanner from sync we
didn't want to make another video with
Tanner for a while and this piece came
along it's like wow I think Tanner would
fit the role of Troy perfectly Troy
being the park ranger who's like man I'm
tired of this [ __ ] and then he's
like nope I gotta do the right thing
remember that or here on forestry land
trying to get away with shooting this
without getting in trouble so so far so
good
there's a way that like yelled at us
right earlier you asked he's like yeah
oh really
I were just doing doing photography yeah
USC yeah they don't even though she said
goes for the throat just put up the room
and it just gonna tell bad people she
said that yeah let's do my another she
said it Wow just think we got away with
it
[Applause]
what cut what cut great can't get much
better than that I've been getting out
of cars since I was like four years old
so it's like three-plus decades of
experience
I'd say reduce a shot so yes blood drink
you tired
[Music]
what's that noise there he is gone go
for help with my phone in the car
[Music]
No
okay
[Music]
take over I treat the up Spiller
get down there
[Music]
so toys like drop it and oh just like
does the opposite of that and we're
gonna shoot something and Troy basically
is kinda the same we'll do it an air can
for getting by Troy yeah
alright we're going hot it's clear out
it alright and you go probably just give
you a cue or some [ __ ] hey check out the
sweet tripod we got we got a carbon
fiber sackler tripod all the way from
Germany Germans make the best camera
equipment it's a pretty sick tripod
honestly I've been looking at a ton
recently and the reason I picked this
one out is because of obviously the fact
that it's carbon fiber so just by
default you know it's a few pounds
lighter than every tripod which is great
when you're hiking out to remote
locations like this but also since we
always have small crews the whole thing
works on like a single lever system so
you pop out each lever and heck you can
even like do this with one person you
can literally just hold the tripod
relock it on your own and then boom the
whole thing is still working and you
only need two hands to do it not two
people and it's even strong enough to
hold our huge jib arm it's called the H
something HD something it's a high
definition tripod is an HD tripod you
can tell because it's so crispy
[Music]
and we're getting so much wind noise and
so much fuzz anyone got stuck if they
don't want sometimes when you don't know
with massage and there is when you don't
work the elf you must exactly your own
sock said I know I got hurt with my
father going into it let's press the
throne into the chapter
there is
[Music]
yeah 6rl all right
one more take here I have my wind socks
[Applause]
you can deal with it all right I used to
deal - listen it's not my job anymore
I'm done look at the list me hey Janine
actually not so like you're not like so
exhausted or not you have a good time
cell but just you want to get home yeah
you know that's thing from the top again
right here you had your gun in your
hands so you're like going oh [ __ ] here
Wow
you also have like this shirt I need to
act like I'm putting on clothes and
David sighs oh boy for the first take
here when you walk in hold a pistol on
this hand and kind of keep it a waist
level okay I'm gonna try this tracking
all way up to here okay put the shirt in
first then the pistol on top of it just
on top of the back yep and then after
that I'll rise up and be cool that's
right comfort right thank you fine okay
look man it's not my job anymore all
right all right I'll uh I'll check it
myself I'm a way out so we'll see you
around yeah okay great that's cool even
though I was worried that you changing
the tongue so severely would affect your
stuff but it actually think bounces it
back out so it's cool all right let's go
in and get this gun shot and then let's
burn rubber so yeah basically just kind
of like uh
having it like parsley and just kind of
like giving a tug and going around like
that or maybe like just giving a Tagum
and putting it in yeah give it a tug and
putting it in that's what I'm all about
all right I've been married long enough
that that's as good as it gets so the
piece like this salmon I want to do an
experiment we want to make something
that was compelling that got your
interest it got people watching
connected without going crazy with
visual effects instead we wanted to see
how gripping of the piece we could make
that just relied on writing
cinematography visual storytelling
acting you know like the core essentials
of actual moviemaking because the great
masters of filmmaking out there is
they're not great at coming up with like
crazy special-effects setups they're
good at coming up with real solid
storytelling that's what gets you to
watch something and if we ever want to
move into more long-form storytelling
we're gonna have to figure that out too
and to be fair we've had shots of it and
you guys have seen you know
demonstrations and pieces like Ted there
or sing or Daisy but we got to keep our
skills up and you got to keep practicing
so this piece in particular was us
really setting out to see if we could
make something that really gripped
people from the start without having to
deep rely on any you know fancy After
Effects work also to do like a short
film like this it was only really
possible because of the supporters that
we've had on patreon so for those of you
who are helping us out there thank you
very much it actually let us gather
through it let us bring together actors
and do we needed to do to tell a story
because of the good it's just gonna do a
visual experiment you don't need a huge
crew for that you just need a lot of
computers and we got lots of computers
so you guys found the characters
interesting or the sumit okapi was
really cool or you found yourself
getting bored one minute in let us know
we want to hear your feedback we want to
hear your reviews so that we can keep
growing and keep figuring out how to
make better movies yeah
you